chiedo a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa dj ed oggi
stiamo su happy meal saga devo dirvi una
cosa abbastanza importante ragazzi che
dobbiamo ci sarà un pochettino diverso
dal solito perché altrimenti io quando
gioco a the peawees lago sempre su
browse levels per giocare appunto ai
vostri livelli a quelli più belli della
settimana l'unica cosa ragazzi che i
server di happy meals non si sa per
quale mistico motivo sembra che sia
imploso qualcosa perché non carica un
cazzo gli unici che caricano ragazzo ai
livelli quelli ufficiali che sono questi
che dovrebbero partire tra poco ed i
ragazzi questi livelli se devo essere
sincero io non li ho mai fatti perché
sono sempre andato su sull'altra sezione
di happy meals e ho fatto piuttosto
discorso appunto per dirvi che è
possibile che vedrete un qualcosa di
diciamo un po diverso dal solito va
comunque a partiamo con il primo non c'è
nulla che possiamo fare ma che cazzo ne
frega a me tato non è mio amico
[ __ ] tv ragazzi che cazzo ci fa un
ambulanza poi nel medioevo non lo so
vabbé attraversiamo la strada viaggio
nel tempo ragazzi dovrei usare sta roba
qua per andare a scuola e fantastico
ragazzi ma hamas di quattro un po
spuntata alzano cosa che cazzo è un
giorno di te io avevo chiesto un paio di
bistecche e non una cosa così comunque
grazie nell'offerta va vado avanti chi
cazzo è quello che cos'è grazie a dio mi
ha salvato
chissà che cosa danno in televisione o
no buono fido buono fido io faccio io
passo ok ma io io comando di nota no non
ci credo non ci può ragazzi
la storia andiamo a di essere
interrogato ed è per questo che un gioco
osti livelli perché so già che non mi
piacciono mai con il padre di gli occhi
mi sto aspettando ma [ __ ]
inglobati la mia macchina ragazzi cazzo
stiamo andando però devo notare ok ok
investito qualche gangsta piscosi
buonomo sa dirmi dove l'ikea ok ok
perfetto mi sa dire mi sa di no ragazzi
un giorno vi insegnerò la mia tattica di
guida come stendersi sul cruscotto e
tentare si va dai ragazzi non è normale
buongiorno l'interessante macchina nuova
a km zero e ragazzi poi non sto neanche
capello dove stiamo andando cioè io ma
io vado avanti così cos'è o rapinato una
banca se adesso ha capito il lavoro che
fa sto tizio mamma mia che
professionista rana stans love and robin
share
che cazzo ragazzi io ho paura ho paura
di giocare stessi livelli qui o non so
che penso possa uscir fuori ciao vorrei
che non vale tenersi sulla staccionata e
così sono bravi tutti cazzo ragazzi non
c'è anche è diventato buono anche come
rampa cazzo fantastico cos'è ok ok ok
scusa ragazzi togliamoci lecco gli anni
prima che mi diano la colpa perché io
siete tutti i testimoni che non ho fatto
niente è che non mi si venga a dire che
poi sono stato io perché non sono stato
io
ragazzi scrivete nei commenti se pensate
io possa vincere chi ha scommesso su di
me è sempre una scommessa valida quella
su di me hai capito brutto stronzo che
cazzo mi guardi così ho vinto qualcuno
adesso si ferma e mi dice perché perché
quel [ __ ] mi ha [ __ ] la macchina
torna indietro bastardo ragazzi santità
e mi ha [ __ ] la macchina non si sa
perché ma per pezzo di merda ma
[ __ ] sono caduto un [ __ ] e
sono ancora vivo non si sa come che
raiola sul cazzi suoi lurido vieni qui
vanno ancora ecco vedete sono più veloce
così ce la posso fare di più bastardo
pieni pieni steve non deve andare con la
mia macchina ma [ __ ] vieni qua in
4 dove cazzo fatta capo tar la macchina
vj l'unico uomo in grado di apportare
una macchina con una bici da un attimo
dobbiamo andare non so dove
perché c'è una tizia
sta mutando per strada che cazzo fa
quella uno struzzo uno struzzo uno
struzzo mi mancava non so perché c'è uno
struzzo ragazzi non lo so perché
continui alto livello perchè ho paura ho
paura degli struzzi
cercate di capirmi venitemi incontro
perché non ce la faccio devo riuscire a
fare un qualche acrobazia epica serie
squadra che sono troppo preso tipo così
questa tipo questa mamma mia juve che
padre c'hai che padre c'hai che padre
fantastico c'hai fai vedere cosa ti ha
insegnato vai e conquista il mondo chi
cazzo è successo
stiamo cadetto vinto corsa al polo nord
che cazzo è stato ragazzi questa devo
fare ma tale muovetevi pezzi di merda ma
ragazzi questo è schiavismo nei
confronti dei folletti cast michael si
ragazzi ai folletti conquisteremo il
mondo siamo troppo forti guardate come
sono presi denim i folletti fantastico
pro sesto robot temporane temporaneo mi
mancava tratto sono partito morto cioè
non so se qualcuno interporranno è morto
subito senza neanche prendere la moneta
sodomizza non mi ha [ __ ] mia
sto cazzo di episodi mi stanno fottendo
di tutto ma no no non mi sono mia mia
[ __ ] di prodotto nel vero senso
della parola ma sono ancora vivo
sono ancora vivo e il nord è morto è
morto lurido stronzo non avrai mio
motorino [ __ ] enrico m
ma che cazzo succede ragazzi si è
trasformato in un incontro di press ling
all'ennesima potenza sta roba vecchia
[Musica]
fenomeno ancora lui avanza incredibile
il salto della morte il salto che cazzo
di cui ho avuto ragazzi dove devo andare
non avrà alla fine sto livello perché
non può essere infinito cioè come
applicazione temporanea infinita c'è nel
senso che corre contro cazzo vuoi ma qua
ci avrà una fine credo che penso di sì
mi avvio la prima volta che vinco tempo
avranno non ci posso credere maria
fottermi la mia roba lurido speed bridge
che cazzo è stato dio che cazzo fa
ragazzi non ho fatto niente io non ho
toccato nulla si è lanciato da solo
questo e cazzo fanno ragazzino dovrei
farlo in bici sto livello credo mai così
io offro io ho posto chi se ne frega
ma vai senza ragazzi fantastico ragazzi
non so perché si è buttato dalla bici
ogni giorno ha unificato niente ma che
cazzo fatto salvami vai ma chi se ne
fotte
mamma mia oggi è tutto così come cazzo
viene viene chi se ne fotte vai così
molon donna tiro
ragni human ranno e cos'è sta roba
misfits fino al casinò suo livello non
sa che cazzo c'è un ufo che per che
quello sta guidando con un cestino sexy
abbiamo perso il pilota abbiamo perso
pilota può essere un problema
io devo rimanere qua devo rimanere
dentro non so che sono stati notando i
ragazzi siete in buone mani
ok inviarmi [ __ ] il pilota nel vero
senso della parola quindi e la grangia
the virato smi armi a ritmi sta
risucchiando un ufo e di zio ma se
timbro il biglietto mi porti a casa
no perché sul pole ma funziona così
belle che ogni terra che cos'è sta roba
devo farlo mimì questo mi ispira un
casino già scheggia che c'è terror va
benissimo
devo chi è quel tizio ma ciao così
triste
sestak arrivo a darti una mano bravo zio
allora scott amiche racconta la
barzelletta così non fermo fermo
successo preso ho preso una punta dove
la metto st punta lada chi gliela infilo
nel ca pranzi perché hai visto e
attaccato ai panni stesi [ __ ]
ragazzi credo che mi sia entrato di
dietro il coso per stendere i panni non
ne sono sicuro togliti e già che ci sono
prendo i pantaloni grazie ragazzi non
capisco se è un pene oppure se è il
costo per stendere i panni no ho i miei
dubbi i ragazzi di prova perché sono
rimasti incastrati sì ma l'aspetto di un
attimo amico mio sconta un attimo ti
volevo raccontare st barzelletta apriate
ci sono due uomini uno che si lancia da
un palazzo è l'altro che lo segue mi
sono ok non ho attaccato le braccia
buongiorno ne dispiace se vi appoggio
sarà tipi incastrato col pene nella
testa di un tizio c'è una cosa io non lo
so il livello più trash che abbiamo in
fatto in vita mia sono ancora vivo sono
ancora vivo cadendo la chilometri sono
ancora vivo sono sono ok qualcuno mi
deve spiegare come cazzo ho fatto a
chiudere da quattro chilometri di
altezza essere ancora vivo non so perché
spero che perché è fuggito un gorilla
all ha detto stronzo vieni qui vieni
quello lì la scimmia niente banale per
te niente banane per te affanculo
ragazzi stiamo così è scattato qualcosa
ragazze sta andando in perché vi sia
scassato tutto la croce non ho già
copiato perché è un gorilla mi ha
[ __ ] al braccio
guido stronzo di un gorilla fornitore di
mani dove ti sei nascosto ragazzi lo
prenderò prima o poi vi giuro che lo
prenderò li farò un culo così perché mi
fotte le mani nonno che cazzo stai
facendo
c'è un gorilla che vuole stuprare o mio
dio che è pieno e pieno di gorilla
adesso non so visto e sto inseguendo io
se mi stanno inseguendo non ho ben
capito ma ho visto così ragazzi ho
rischiato veramente grosso farsi
inglobare da un grido non è bello però
sicuro questo livello uguale a
supermario ma forse perché è super mario
mio avviso scelto senza neanche leggere
il titolo credo sia appunto supermario
dove è mario devo trovare il mio amico
minchia mai fatto da dio non ci posso
credere ragazzi già sto facendo
devo arrivare a 857 non incidenti cento
la mia bici continuo senza [ __ ] la
bici ragazzi [ __ ] la bici la prossima
volta continua senza perché tanto a me
ne frega una macchia la prossima volta
me ne vado a piedi perché tanto non me
ne frega un cazzo di niente
raga mi sono fracassato i [ __ ] ok
ora ancora vivo con mezza ruota
ok palla ragazzi mi sono detto gianni
benissimo e mezz'ora che però la forza
parte non ci riesco ma chi se ne frega
questi ragazzi se vi dove è piaciuto
cosa al solito lasciato un commento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook come
non i video trovate nella descrizione
sensi degli scritti iscrivetevi missili
vediamo il prossimo video bei ragazzi